[Music]
I was just wondering if you wanted to um
you know go out sometime you want to get
a coffee now yes now
I'll just hang on when I wake up well I
know I'm gonna be her name is Sadie
I mean I know this sounds crazy but I
think she might be the one
who goes along with you she really is
great you'll see
a word she goes to them I bet she hasn't
even seen your text she does travel a
lot for work go to her I'm going to
London
[Music]
yeah that is amazing mate 5 000 miles as
far as a girl you've only met once
especially if she's the one who ghosted
you
no no she didn't ghost me she just
doesn't have an international calling
plan all right
[Music]
all right
where am I oh God you you have the wrong
guy I'm a former wait wait
foreign
oh my God oh my God
you got me kidnapped and tortured all
after one day
I saw the rock you're the one who blew
to London
it was a romantic gesture
get rebound your Hunter on the cockpit I
want her like
bigger than you and me
it never occur to you that he could be a
foreign asset trying to compromise your
mission
who the hell are you
I'm the boyfriend
[Music]
can you trust me is that a joke
the guy just pulled up a horse well is
he still on the horse he just went
inside the place problem solved
do what you gotta do and call me when
it's done
[Music]
okay I don't want to hurt you if you
could just pay Paulie the money that you
own coffee he's not staying
yes sir
hey is that guy dead
looks pretty dead
[Music]
what is it done I think I killed the
cook this is why I don't stand up for
you this not good though tomorrow first
thing I want to go and see that
degenerate cowboy and straighten this
out yeah I only agreed to kill that guy
Walter because my kid's in jail I need
the money to get him a lawyer Welcome to
the Jungle
thank you we're in this together now go
poly Russo 100 Grand you got a week to
come up with the bread I got a lot of
friends law and otherwise you've always
got to forgive my death you really want
to take this road with me
you are welcome to find out my friend my
son's detention hearing is in three days
I don't even have a lawyer yet who talks
Money Talks
right maybe we can help each other my
mom's she's Rich get me out of here her
dad's working on it okay that's supposed
to make me feel better I want you to
find Jackie and I want you to bring him
to me directly
hey I'm supposed to be scared of you not
to get a gun you are nothing but an
Aaron boy I'll bust you all around okay
all right let me see it
hold on can I put my clothes on first
oh
there's a raise a keeper I will put up
the money for your son it seems like the
right thing to do she's known you for
two minutes she's ready to write you a
check this is very embarrassing I'll
find Jackie again this time you're gonna
laugh come on boy do I look like I'm
joking to you you gotta go take care of
my kids
[Music]
bottom line is you make some very
serious best with me you lost I don't
understand you mom because of dying or
because your acting career didn't work
out oh my God
oh
this ain't me scared boy this is me
pissed off
do we have a lawyer
I'm sorry your honor I apologize I'm new
in town got a little lost
[Music]
oh
it was all a dream the name's Mirage
come on kill
Taps yeah
a mirage remember
[Music]
starvey British intelligence we're here
with the approval of your state
department
I've been sent to ask you to go into
Mexico and collect a prisoner
we believe is planning a terrorist event
in London
for this Ranger I think of like going up
against you
foreign
you're in the UK now protocol is
everything
you agree that that was quite Reckless
there's two tabs in this game
it was on a run
I was doing a hunting
you've got their attention
the fortune in the favor is the Bold
shoot me them hands
good luck to your Ranger
I know that this road has been very hard
and yet here you are
building This Magnificent family
what's going on in that head of yours
something little piece of it he said Dad
they're not afraid of anything
but I am
afraid of losing someone I love
Dominic Toretto you're about to learn
all about fear boom
such a beautiful life filled with love
and family I never got a chance
you stole that from me
my future
my family
and now
I'm gonna break yours
be by peace
[Music]
[Applause]
he's coming for you with everything
what's the plan Dom I'm not sure anymore
one of us might not come back from this
but we have to fight
never accept death when suffering is old
[Music]
he's trying to tear us apart
today I race to stop the Bloodbath
[Music]
that's the problem with having such a
big family how do you choose the ones
you save
[Music]
[Applause]
you still know how to drive
what do you think
it's showtime
[Music]
the game recognizes game
I'm coming for you son
[Music]
here they come you will never be able to
break my family
[Music]
good morning sunshine you gotta be
kidding me
[Music]
let's try that again but ninja stars
hey why do we pick a fruit shaped
exactly like my head just stop talking
you're ruining my concentration you're
fine chill he's gonna die
[Music]
did you hear that what was that
well nothing we can do you guys want to
grab pizza
then I can
pick it
what the heck are those things those are
like little Shreks to me
we've prepared our whole life for this
Hannah
oh my God
what happened is
so you were baby turtles who made
contact with mystery goo well we prefer
the term ooze but yeah it's like more
like it's just it's rolls off the tongue
better yeah
it's nice right
[Music]
foreign
okay chop it off chop it off let's do it
oh we got him now
you know what I'm thinking they're
probably sharper stairs somewhere else
we're thieves but we helped the wrong
person steal the wrong thing and unleash
the greatest evil the world has ever
known
red Wizards created an army of the
undead
sounds lovely quite the opposite I know
I was being ironic I find irony as a
blazer because he who wields it most
especially you're not a lot of fun are
you
how are we gonna pull this off we're
gonna need a team
follow me to the orifice
the orifice
I'll go lost
I don't mind that
she missed
no that's not good
I just sick of failing we couldn't die
there's worse things than dying
I lost everything that ever mattered to
me and if we quit now that's for nothing
I don't want to see you die which is why
I'm Gonna Leave the Room
oh
the bridge is protected by an ancient
trap we must not trigger the mechanism
I may have triggered the mechanism
so
sorry
I miss the desert
foreign
and I miss waking up every morning
wondering what wonderful Adventure the
new day will bring to us
those days have come and gone Perhaps
Perhaps not
[Music]
I don't believe in magic
a few times in my life
I've seen things
things I can't explain
and I've come to believe it's not so
much what you believe
how hard you believe
[Music]
who is this man I'm her Godfather
get back
I'm gonna tell you something
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
met a girl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
[Music]
came back a total dick oh please he left
out some important information but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
and make things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
oh
[Music]
foreign
are you ready
for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
a beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it out what
just never noticed how black your eyes
were they were replaced by my father as
a method of torture he he picked a
pretty set
yeah
[Music]
go away
come here
[Music]
what is she
John we have tallies approaching
[Music]
you still don't remember a thing
I don't remember any of it
I only remember
The Interpreter
[Music]
why he wants his job I need the money
don't disappoint turn out to be a pain
in the ass no not me sir
money isn't the reason he wants this job
and Taliban killed his son
stop the vehicle sergeant we don't want
to go down this road you're out of your
bounds Ahmed you're here to translate
actually I'm here to interpret
if Tyler's approaching
well I want
back down for three weeks this family
believed you were dead we are the man
your life it wasn't enough for him to
carry me across those mountains
[Music]
oh he's hiding in a hole somewhere I
should be in that hole
everything all right John no
everything's not all right there is a
hook in me Ahmed and his family are in
trouble we can't intervene
I am gonna have to get him out myself
listen you're gonna be alone
you go to adapt
this is what you got
if you can give me the location if I can
get him out of the country it's too
dangerous
you become very popular with the Taliban
I miss you love you Daddy
you think if I could be free of this
death I wouldn't be
you think I have a choice
there is no choice no I Won't
Back Down
[Music]
your days of fighting for the so-called
greater good
are over
this is our chance to troll the truth
the concepts of right and wrong from
everyone for centuries to come
you're fighting to save an ideal that
doesn't exist
never did
you need to pick a side
thank you foreign
[Music]
let them know you're here
let the fights begin why watch out
Roy get up you know you cost me a lot of
money tonight you got 48 hours to make
this up to you
you haven't heard from Roy we don't go
this long without hearing from him get a
little worried sometimes he's a vagabond
fighting people for scrap
uncut diamonds into your truck and you
know what will happen if this doesn't
get the bar in the next 24 hours do you
got a brother right the one with a
beautiful wife and the two daughters
what does Jill have to do with this I
need collateral
nice to see you you want to come with me
for a couple days gee yeah why not
[Music]
they're there
did you get us into Roy 50 million in
diamonds
where's my diamonds three SUVs and some
guys robbed her hello
girls are gone the three of us are
getting my family back
set up sniper and cover us come in
position
[Music]
[Applause]
the question my honor
tell me something
you can go anywhere
[Music]
another timeline
Another Universe
so why do you want to stay in a fight to
save this one
this is the world where my mom lives
I'm not gonna lose her again
[Music]
time has a pattern
that it can't help reliving
different people different worlds
drawn to each other with magnets
[Music]
it's my face so my face
if you were to go into the past
you have no idea what the consequences
could be Bruce I could fix things you
could also destroy everything
kept me happening
completely broke the universe
besides we've been waiting for you
created a world with no metahumans
and now there's no one to defend us
want some help
oh you're
you are yeah
I'm Batman
[Music]
if I can't undo what I did
if I can't get back
there might not be a future
what's the plate Batman what do we do we
try not to die
it's not Clark
it's Cara Barry
Barry what are you doing our kids are
gonna want to see this
seven years ago one incredible story
blew up the internet when I was 22 I got
involved with the Russian mafia I was a
frat boy on a class trip Mrs Igor he's
here for your protection he's very
dangerous to talk to or hang out with
him all I want to do is hang out with
him I did not speak Russian
all I knew how to say was
[Applause]
it was literally the best summer of my
life we robbing this guy
23 years after those events
the story continues what is wrong with
this shirt
get out machine not today brother not
today my dad showed up you paid money to
see my son tell his made-up story about
robbing a train for the million times
it's a true story it took about two
seconds before he started making me
mental look look
he's a monster
are you the machine ma'am the party's
outside 23 years ago he was told the
only thing my father ever cared about
sorry this is some sort of tick tock
prank I'm about to lose my [__] it's
definitely a prank clearly that's a fake
gun
or not they're coming with me back to
Russia
why are you talking about fast like
Heroes speed or something cause I'm on
speed oh more drugs
[Applause]
take off that shirt and show those sobs
who you really are now you gotta party
with me
he's the machine
[Music]
fine I'll just shoot him in the leg
oh my God I'm going to freaking hell I
killed a man well
technically you killed several men
[Music]
I can hear you being quiet mom
I am
hope I didn't ice your game man
no one my age says those words in that
order
it's just
see my little man not be my little boy
all the time
for years I've been taking care of this
little boy
making sure he is loved
but he feels like he belongs wherever he
wants to be
he wants to go out into the world and do
great big things
not bad kid
and what I worry about most
I love you Mars
they won't look out for you like us
want to get out of here
wherever you go from here you have to
promise to take care of that little boy
for me
sure he never forgets where he came from
[Music]
and
he never doubts that he is loved
and he never lets anyone
tell him that he doesn't belong there
you gotta promise miles
I promise
[Music]
we are supposed to be the good guys we
are
[Music]
I have terrible news your grandfather is
dead I don't even know him they want me
to fly to Rome tomorrow night to settle
his Affairs I mean shouldn't I stay here
and work on my marriage Kristen start
thinking about you
I landed safe in Italy
Coliseum oh what where is it can we go
back we have to go to the funeral
what did my grandfather do
thank you
is going on
yeah my dying wish is that you be the
new boss the valbara family
I've got a lot going on at home my son
just went to college and my husband just
cheated on me no
[Music]
no
no no no
we need someone who's level heading
I'm assuming and empathetic did you just
call me pathetic
we are in the middle of a war with our
enemies
we have to kill those Romanos before
they kill us
like Godfather oh right yeah I never saw
the Godfather
okay look it's really hard to find three
and a half hours
how are we supposed to appear strong
when she is this you look like a
librarian
finally hot Italian men yet
to kill the boss the boss takes care of
business I made muffins
I'm a little tired of this war my family
is tired of this war oh my gosh
TripAdvisor does not lie can I
can I scoop
you think
hi I'm still in the dark here
figure of speech
[Music]